he's got massive claws and a biting
mouth somebody what does he claw them or
does he mess with the bike
the shot is one of those flex shots
check this out
the thing that makes gollum work the
most for me is just the lip animation
the lip animation is so solid so i have
a little pause at one moment you see a
little elbow shake it's like do the
pores stretch do the elbows shake
today's episode is brought to you by
squarespace stick around to the end to
see how you can get 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain hey everybody welcome back to
another episode of visual effects
artists react i am super excited for
this episode because we are joined by
robin lockham from dna he's the
animation director and global head of
animation over at that studio he's
worked on some incredible films avatar
king kong i mean i could go on we won't
we'll look at the clips together and
talk about it this could be awesome
thank you for joining us thanks for
having me you're at d were you anywhere
before that before dina was at weta for
a good period about seven years and i
did a little into ireland doing a bit of
star wars and then friends job before
yeah yeah i just did a little bit of
star wars
i've been very fortunate in my career so
i think i get at the right time but yeah
it's been it's been brilliant well let's
go ahead and jump into some of these
clips here and take a look
[Music]
so you got your start at what a digital
working on this little indie film called
the return of the king obviously the
lore ring series is very special to me
i'm a very big fan but you know it also
has a lot of landmarks in terms of
visual effects primarily in golem
gollum for me is still
one of those landmarks from animation
for visual effects because it's an
empathetic creature it was annie circus
put some efforts into making a character
which the audience could believe and not
go why am i looking at cg right now
everyone's looking at well that's gollum
i'm not looking at siege anymore
everyone knows it's not real but it made
an evolution to be a legitimate actor so
working on it was is just amazing i mean
i was just a bigger fan as you actually
this is a couple of my shots coming up
and so when you say like you did that
shot you're given like this plate and
then this rig and your job is to
literally animate all those little tiny
dials and knobs that translate to moving
those muscles on his face yeah so are
you responsible for the facial yeah
animation the eyes the neck and
shoulders and arms as well yeah
everything in the shot okay i guess in
my head i just kind of figured there'd
probably be like two or three artists
working on a single shot but you did it
all as well yeah
every animator had the whole show
because most of performance is always
connected to the body and the eyes are
connected to the mouth and they yeah so
you have cascading you have to work them
out together the thing that makes gollum
work the most for me is just the lip
animation the lip animation is so solid
because that's one of the hardest things
to replicate in an automated way these
days like you have this incredible
performance from andy circus and people
think that oh yeah it's just motion
capture they just extracted that and
stuck it on a model good to go i feel
like the reality
is that no there's an actual layer of
interpretation from animators and
artists that have to actually make that
work yeah the animators are they do
a massive amount of work i mean look at
the lips lips are a bag of flesh you can
tighten them you can flex them out when
they push together they they kind of
crush in and they they can sometimes
stick you have lip sticky which is
another tool you put sticky on the side
when open
i know it sounds gross but yeah
so when when you open your lips they
kind of like sometimes yeah they look
like they peel and if you look at it
yeah there we are yep there we go
like what a subtle thing that you can't
just like pull from mocap you can't
sometimes get in capture because it's
emotionally driven when you tense up
your mouth your lip will thin when you
have a nose raise obviously that's
pulling other muscles around the on the
lip here you just have to kind of look
you have to watch and look and get those
kind of fins and flesh it's really
really tricky stuff yeah but it's that's
that's why it works
you know another really interesting
thing about gollum is the fact that he
is so emotive you know he can really
feel the emotions that he's experiencing
but to a certain degree gollum is kind
of cheap mode because he's not fully
human and so you're able to kind of
bypass that uncanny valley a little bit
100 and i think that's why it worked i
think that's why from here onwards you
see characters like that and that's why
they work because they have that little
play where you can believe into it it's
not like trying to be a perfect human
it's crazy how old this is
yeah yeah we're literally coming up on
the 20-year anniversary of this movie i
think it's kick-started so many things
from there
i remember james cameron saying that his
inspiration for pursuing avatar was
seeing gollum up on the big screen and
being like all right we're finally here
we can do it i'm gonna make avatar yeah
that's actually right
that's right
so i was very lucky to work a lot on the
counter tour i did all the walk cycles
run cycles for it but yeah it's super
fun to animate
when it's getting stuck and caught up on
things like that are you kind of
animating the destruction at least like
approximately also yeah the team did
this one they were absolutely trying to
work the environment as well yeah
because it's like what i'm seeing here
that's really fascinating is that like
he's interacting with the environment
but the environment is reacting through
simulations like stuff breaking and
falling and whatnot so you have to
animate those things getting knocked out
and then someone else takes that
animation as the inspiration for the sim
sim yeah exactly yeah okay we got a lot
of freedom to try and be expressive and
like use those moments the shot coming
up where he jumps off the cliff that's
why i animated that one oh cool
i didn't know how to be threatening i
was like he's got massive claws and a
biting mouth somebody what does he claw
them or does he mess with the bike
oh what an interesting like dilemma
you're like so when you actually see the
shot you'll notice i do both oh
because i just didn't
i was like i have to up the ante so he
kind of snaps and claws
in a certain rhythm this is one of the
shots where i got a lot of pride because
i was in the cinema and when you hear
the audience going gasping yeah and i'm
like oh yeah just it makes you day
there's so many like new things from
like a cg pipeline that i saw in this
movie too from like materials that were
emitting light and of course the fact
that it's all shot with a virtual
production style so you have a lot of
handheld camera work this wasn't this
movie the birth of virtual production
like i'd never really seen that sort of
thing before this like i know robert
zemeckis had done some experiments with
some virtual production type stuff but i
really feel it was james cameron who
really kind of like pushed the envelope
on having that sort of like cg stuff in
real time on set i mean ultimately he
built his whole film around it working
with him like this was a leap this was
definitely a leap of production where
just the quantity of shots was doing you
know some movies have maybe about 800
shots that's a big movie for vfx i think
the return of the king had maybe 1400
which was huge back in the day and this
was like three and a half thousand i
think wow and when it was made it was
like unheard of it's like a fully cg
film i mean essentially yeah
[Music]
you worked on this movie after working
on king kong because king kong came
before this what were some of the things
you animated for that movie i animated
kong climbing up the vampire state
building oh no way really yeah that was
very cool iconic
[Music]
three a one-handed two-legged climb yeah
a little twist on the classic yeah one
arm climbing yeah i guess he's just got
toes of steel just like gripping onto
the windows yeah well it's hard because
he's injured at this point and he has to
feel a little laborious so i have my
little paws at one moment you see a
little elbow shake he's trying to get
his arm up oh man it's like do the pores
stretch do the elbows shake
muscle vibrations yeah right so it's
just small bits and pieces just to try
and add a little bit of substance of
what kong's going through it's a joy for
an animator you've got such a great
beast here to kind of work with did have
a performance from andy circus as well
and then we could go into it further
make it more gorilla that's right i
totally forgot andy circus played king
kong in this movie yeah he's got a big
outfit and uh
[Music]
the hardest thing we had naomi watts is
on a card we didn't have a digital
double of her so for those who don't
know a card is basically just a
two-dimensional element imagine a
picture literally on a card in this case
would be the photography of the actress
and if the card twists well it's a card
and you you know it doesn't work so it
does look like she's on the card it's
hard to animate because the fact is
she's filmed on a stage quite still yeah
and you have to apply that motion
of sway and then i'm on a card so i
can't twist it that way or this way it's
hard to tip it that when her hair's not
doing too much yeah that's a great way
to implement live action photography
into a cg scene because it looks great
from this one angle but like i guess
you're saying it's like he's holding her
and moving and climbing but she was
filmed without a gorilla holding her so
yeah this time we couldn't get him
available
but it's true and it was a real
challenge for the animators especially
on shots where the camera's moving
around or especially on shots where he's
fighting a dinosaur
you have to be very careful with it
otherwise it can't push it far yeah but
then if you don't push it far enough it
looks like someone's just moving around
it's a fine balance i think i might have
almost caught it but uh yeah it was
really tricky i mean i think it looks
great so why not just have a 3d double
for the actress so i think at that
moment specifically it was a very
important moment to see anne connecting
with kong it was about naomi there so he
couldn't have a digital double there
[Music]
thinking back before you were an
animator is there a film that sticks out
to you something you saw something that
inspired you to start thinking about
animation
yeah um seeing things like clash of the
titans harryhausen and jason the
argonauts and skeletons and all that
kind of mythical fantasy
[Music]
this is one of my favorite sequences
because it's so scary and cool this is
all stop-motion again it's kind of
interesting how stop-motion has really
physical really real but if you notice
the performances they're not
performances of disney you know they're
not hugely kind of gestured it's
actually kind of the precursor i'd say
to more vfx animation than maybe disney
is because it's quite real and it has
certain weight
there's no motion blur as well on on the
guys because they didn't know how to do
motion but then afterwards they had a
tool which added motion blur yeah i
think they called it go motion that's a
good emotion yeah but this is before
that time this is just raw stop-motion
animation where it's like you have to
make sure that your poses are correct
every single frame exactly and it's just
knowing as well where you're going with
those poses to make it work r is so good
i can't believe how good this looks i
think it's because it's stop motion
obviously you've got brilliant lighting
it's going to look like the environment
in fact he's almost out of place yeah
well just the nuance like look at their
swords like they're pushed together yeah
for ray harry house like line it up in
camera and put the sword there and then
he moves the sword then marie harry
house moves the skeleton to the exact
same spot of contact with the sword it's
so precise and there's a whole
compositing thing that's happening in
camera with the stop motion in the
background being filmed at the same time
because there's no green screening or
blue skating happening here no i just
love the action there's so cool design
still things like that jumping over his
feet forward that way and it's that
little animation there as he came to
stop he kind of like scurried a little
bit and went left i mean he didn't have
to do the extra step but it adds a
little tension of like where am i going
he obviously filmed himself doing that i
guess i mean yeah it sells the sense of
motion there you know he's got momentum
and you can't just like
yeah he's like
yeah i think most people don't really
realize just how much subtlety that goes
into how we move and it's an animator's
job to replicate that subtlety rather
than just the motion you know it's an
amazing career because you learn so many
things i always said to an animator you
know you learn something about animation
and you think you know it all and then
you under open a new door and you're
like oh my god i'm starting again so
it's great it goes on forever you keep
learning and learning and learning so
you might learn the physics of someone
how it walks and then so can you make
him walk uh looking upset and it's like
okay well that's different physics then
okay well just learn how to walk now it
has to be sad or or make it trip halfway
through so so many subtleties you learn
and they all have to be believable
because if you look at it on the screen
and it doesn't look right you know
straight away you know yeah so there's a
good deal of craft that goes into it
this is so great they were amazing to
see i think i've got a fan for skeletons
i need to do some skeleton movies
hey we got these episodes coming out
every single week so chances are they're
showing up in your recommended feed but
you know what would make that even
better if it shows up in your
subscription feed hit that subscribe
button it helps us out thank you
you owe davey jones your soul
so pirates of the caribbean dead man's
chest had this probably in my opinion
one of the most incredible characters of
all time davey jones and it was one of
the first effect shots we looked at on
this entire show he blew that out with
his cheek nostril
i didn't even realize that oh my god was
it in the very first episode it might
have been because i remember ren was
like they actually kept the eyes from
the original actor and say it like that
now his eyes are real yeah they're
taking it a little bit by actually using
the real eyes red and got an email from
one of the people who worked out he's
like actually
that's 100 cg
[Laughter]
because it's like you see the behind the
scenes photo of bill nye he's got like
these marks around his face and whatnot
but his eyes are actually painted black
and i made the presumption that like
they kept the real eyes but in reality
it's like to make those eyes work with
the rest of davey jones head they had to
be rendered and
it was very good
look at that that's such a great shot in
there having these kind of he's smoking
at the same time and it's coming out the
side the shot is one of those flex shots
check this out
long shot holding it interacting with
the pipe there's smoke you can't tell
yeah that's the winning shot isn't it
beautiful acting davey jones is in my
opinion the first cg character i saw
that looked 100 real oh it's brilliant
and i think this was done after gollum
came out as well but this was brilliant
i remember seeing this going whoa this
is such an expressive character bill nye
again is an expressive face but this the
way they've put it all together all that
tentacle work the nose flesh around the
lip and how the lip pushes together as
well as we know there's nothing there
stopping it but it feels heavy and it
feels connected yeah it's such a it was
it was brilliant the lighting is also
just so perfect the shading the
subsurface scattering the secondary
emotion that's like half physics half
hand animation when you can add that
that physics
like on top of it yeah you know like oh
let's just do like some cloth slim slash
technical stim slash whatever around the
hand animation suddenly it just like
gives it all nice like twenty percent
quality it's almost like a doubling a
layer of our skin fascia and fat it just
it adds so much calculations you can't
keyframe yeah and it really really
affects it oh it's brilliant but
obviously the tentacles again they're
doing a mind of their own as well as
having a dynamic interaction yeah you're
totally right it's like there's physics
there's swaying but then they're also
curling up yeah like if you were to chop
the tail off of a gecko or something
this still is going to like curl around
and whatnot and we're kind of seeing
that at play here on top of the physics
being driven by an actual animation of
his head
life is cruel
why should the afterlife be any
different what jumps out to you as like
the most challenging aspect of doing
david jones apart from the tentacles
they obviously solved what this
character is going to be the difficult
bit would be you've got such a big top
lip and you've got no nose right and
you've got a bottom lip and you have to
get this expression it's almost like
he's snarling a lot because then that
snarl pushes a lot of movement so the
hardest bit would probably trying to get
the lines red when you've got this big
almost like a moustache really isn't it
yeah
exactly it kind of just looks like a big
mustache but it has flesh so i think the
hardest would be just trying to deliver
those lines correctly when you don't
have that range of motion of the top lip
that you'd usually expect you're totally
right i only just now realized that sort
of like complexity there that challenge
yeah i was like
i was gonna bring up i i distinctly
remember him going
yeah and then we just saw it but i think
it's just fleshy and like flesh stuff as
we talked about it's really hard to do
because there's no knowledge of each
other and because it feels so heavy in
flesh and you've got little kind of
suckers on the side that are blow holes
as well reacting that flesh and that
simulator really helps bind the
character obviously bill nye's done a
tremendous job coming up with this
character which has helped influence all
the animation much like zoe saldana did
but the theory really nails it but oh
it's it's just so well done i imagine
they would have to over emphasize
certain types of animation just to get
that sort of translation across yeah
absolutely absolutely i think it's very
fleshy it's it's dampening down a lot
because it looks like it pins from the
cheekbone down to the lip so all that
motion underneath that you'd really have
to push it but i think maybe the
performance from bill overemphasizes
that so you can really lean into his
kind of character and throw the lips up
a bit higher maybe push the bottom lip a
bit more to try and announce it over
announce these things and get more
reaction from the face so how much do
you think was bill nye like really
specifically overacting on set versus
not acting enough in the animator having
to up those sort of actions i would say
that bill would probably have a good
handle of what he was doing but again a
lot of things when you go on set and
have an actor and then try and put it
into cg you do lose a lot of emotion so
sometimes you have to push it a little
bit and see jesus to get that read it
reminds me a little bit of like back in
the day with the original plan of the
apes where you have all of this really
intense looking makeup on top of a
person's face and it really just dampens
the performance yeah like you're not
able to really get some of those
subtleties coming through i imagine it's
a very similar challenge here but they
have the flexibility of being able to
like you know show it yeah and also
because you've got all these tentacles
and they are driven by the face as well
you almost got extra bits of energy that
can add to a performance so as you move
your lip up well then you've got six
tentacles on the side coming with it as
well right okay
adding another pronunciation to that
motion it's like the tentacles moving
help inform that the upper lip moved
yeah kind of yeah okay i think you know
we're at a stage now it's kind of funny
how much we've gone because these are
conversations we used to have back in
davy jones day but now everyone knows it
you know
thanks to you guys doing channels like
this as well people have knowledge and
and like the standard is up and i love
that fact it means that i can look
forward into things i
don't know what about you know so we
don't have to solve those problems you
can look in really weird directions and
see how things go you know hey you it's
saturday you're eating breakfast a bowl
of cereal but you know what you're the
kind of person needs two bowls of
cereals and this episode only covers one
well guess what we have a solution for
that cododigital.com we have extended
episodes on the site so when you eat two
bowls of cereal the episode will last
for both of them check it out free trial
we've looked at a lot of things on this
show at this point and we get most of
our suggestions from the comments but
i'm curious what scenes we've already
looked at that perhaps need a second
look that's a good one i like that one
yeah red suggestion please
visual effects am i right okay
here's what you're thinking you're like
man i would love to be good at visual
effects but jake i just i don't have the
time to spend the next five years of my
life training myself getting good at it
well that's that's true in the world of
visual effects you need to put the time
in but courtesy of today's sponsor
squarespace you do not have to do that
when it comes to creating a beautiful
and effective website for your small
business or for you now you might not
know this but for years i struggled to
find the right way to get corridor
digital a website i tried different
services i tried this and that i knew
nothing guess what actually fixed it in
the end squarespace it was super simple
because they have beautiful
award-winning templates that was years
ago now they have so many more services
that are so much more efficient
effective and great for your small
business or service the first thing that
squarespace has is
video studio tools which allow you to
create videos directly within
squarespace that's a super awesome tool
that you now get access to boom with
your squarespace subscription they also
have members only areas that you can
create with your website which allow you
to give members only access to different
people different types of audiences who
are coming into your site they also have
other phenomenal features like email
campaigns if you want to do that format
and get an email out to a bunch of
people and they've got some of the best
analytics in the game which allow you to
better understand your site who's coming
to it and how to better tailor it to
those people so as a person who has used
squarespace extensively before they even
sponsored this channel and now seeing
all the things that you can do with it
now it truly is like knowing visual
effects without knowing visual effects
so anyways if you guys are interested in
getting started for yourself and getting
10 off your first purchase of a website
or domain click the link in the
description below or go to
squarespace.com
corridor crew say it with me at
squarespace.com
corridor crew and now let's get back to
those visual effects
man that was a wild ride dude robin
thank you so much for hanging out with
us this was a blast thank you so much
for watching we're gonna have to have
you back at some point maybe uh maybe
not too far away maybe a sandy feature
i would love to thank you very much i
really appreciate it it was great just
to go through with detail it's a passion
i love it i always want to do it i just
want to do more more creatures and and
get into more weird stuff
but uh yeah thank you so much it was
great yeah no that was that was really
cool i'm really glad we were able to
like even check out some stuff from like
davey jones and like all these really
like tentpole industry defining moments
like calm it's really crazy though like
yeah you know these temple industries
finding moans like golem which i worked
on and then king kong which i worked on
[Laughter]
i've been fortunate yeah oh then of
course avatar which i worked on
i'm not going to blush
it okay
well thanks again and i will see you in
the next episode because that's how
screens work my eyeballs go through them
nathan
for you